Well, Paul, Isaac,
congratulations.
You are both moving forward into
round three of our competition.
Now, you guys are heading
back to your home forges
to work on yet another iconic
weapon from the Civil War era.
And that weapon is
[music playing]
Ulysses Grant's Donelson sword.
The Donelson sword is a
commemorative blade awarded
to General Ulysses S
Grant for his victory
at Fort Donelson in
February of 1862,
one of the first major Union
victories of the Civil War.
The weapon features a
highly ornate handle
and an engraved blade based
on the popular 1860s officer
sword.
After General Grant's death,
his wife donated the sword
to the Smithsonian
Institute in 1886,
and it remains under
their care to this day.
You have four days
to work on your swords.
Good luck.
See you then.
[music playing]
I'm Isaac Gardner,
and I'm 24 years old.
I'm a full-time jeweler.
As a jeweler, there's a
lot of small detail work
and making sure that
I have something
that's one, comfortable,
and two, strong, and three,
looks amazing.
So as a bladesmith I focus
on the same three aspects.
It's time to quench it.
Oh, OK.
Hopefully, it came out hard.
That's hard.
Oh, I feel so much better.
I need the rear-facing quillon,
and the two clamshell guards,
and the knuckle bow.
It's going to be
something like that.
So now that I have the
components complete
I can move on to
welding them together.
I'm really happy with
how it's looking.
That's so cool.
It's really ornate and complex.
I cut in the channels for my
turquoise and amber inlay.
There we go.
Cool beans.
I've worked really
hard up to this point,
and now I'm so happy with my
General Grant's Donelson sword.
[music playing]
I'm Paul Sutt.
I'm from New Jersey and
I'm a personal trainer.
So I've been a lifelong martial
artist and a weapons expert.
And when I had the opportunity
to learn how to forge,
I jumped on it as
fast as I could.
It's just my passion.
So we're getting
close to quench time.
It's a little tricky for
me because I've never
done a blade this thin before.
I'm nervous as hell.
Two whole days hammering
this sword out.
If something goes
wrong with the quench
there is no time
to do that again.
Here we go.
Don't feel any tings
or pings or anything.
I pull it out and I'm so happy.
It looks straight.
It looks perfect.
So now I'm going to do a little
bit of work on the clamshell,
try to make it look as pretty
as I can as quick as I can.
And then it's going to
be shaping the handle
into a comfortable handle.
Almost.
So I finally got all the
pieces to fit on the tang.
All right.
This entire experience
has been more fun than I
ever imagined it would be.
The blade is a little bit
chunky, but it will kill.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
The sword is made to be
a dueling type of weapon.
So I'm going to try to
deliver the same light slashes
and thrust to this
ballistics dummy.
Paul, you ready for this?
Oh yes, sir.
All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Paul.
Let's talk about your version of
General Grant's Donelson sword.
The weight on this blade is
not that of a dueling sword
because it requires a little bit
more than just wrist movement.
But it is a great cutting sword.
Your edges are sharp.
Even with the harassing cut you
can see they're cutting deeply.
And more importantly,
sir, it will kill.
Isaac, your turn, sir.
Are you ready for this?
I guess.
OK.
[music playing]
All right, Isaac.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
What I like about
it is the time you
took to put these
details that we were
asking for onto your sword.
Every cut was deep.
And not a lot of power
is required when you're
swinging something so light.
But, probably hitting
the bone, your blade
did take a slight bend.
But overall, sir,
your weapon will kill.
Thank you.
[music playing]
Paul, Isaac, you
know what time it is.
Time for the strength test.
A fan favorite and the
cringe-worthy flex test.
And we're going to
flex those blades to 35
degrees in either direction.
If you're still holding
true, we're going to go to 45
degrees in either direction.
Paul, you ready for this?
Not really, but go
ahead and bend away.
[music playing]
Oh!
Oh.
[music playing]
So Paul, as far as the
construction of your blade
goes, the handle's
comfortable, we
saw how will this sword cuts.
You did a good job.
But if you look
into that blade, you
can actually see a dark spot
on both sides of this blade.
And whether that's a
flaw that you picked up
in the forging process
or flaw in the steel,
I have no way of really
telling right now.
The grain structure
on this looks fine.
But having it shatter,
having it pop like that,
that's a big issue.
Mm-hmm.
[music playing]
Well Paul, we absolutely
hate to see that.
You put a lot of
work into your blade.
You made it past
35 on both sides,
but you did break
on the way to 45.
But you're not out
of the fight yet.
Isaac, you've got to survive
both of the 35 degree turns
as well as the official ruling
of 40 degrees towards south.
My heart is in my throat.
This is literally make or break.
[music playing]
Congratulations, man.
Thanks.
[music playing]
Paul, I want to say thank
you for your hard work.
You have what it takes
to fight in this forge.
But, unfortunately, I'm going
to have to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thank you, gentlemen.
This was such a good experience
and it was an honor to compete
against such a good competitor.
Isaac we asked you to build
General Grant's Donelson sword.
You performed phenomenally and
built us something that is not
only functional but absolutely
beautiful and stunning
to look at.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and you, sir, earned
yourself a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
I'm the "Forged in
Fire" champion, baby!
Woo!
How do you feel?
Cloud nine.
Feeling so good.
That's a remarkable
piece of work
and you should be
incredibly proud of it.
Thank you.
There's just too
many feelings going
through my head and my
heart to really process
what's all happening right now.
I can't believe it.
I'm feeling so good.
[music playing]